in september 2001 new york city suffered
a tragedy that rocked the world
20 years later it's been devastated by
covet 19.
yesterday was the deadliest day in new
york with more than 700 coronavirus
deaths the crisis in new york reaching a
critical mass
[Music]
after 9 11 the city came back stronger
what lessons can be learned from this
revival to help new york recover from
covet 19.
[Music]
i'm john fassman the economist u.s
digital editor and i'm also a new yorker
in september 2001 i live in brooklyn
from this side of the river you get a
perfect view of the financial district
where the twin towers once stood
the towers were right there where where
freedom tower is now where that gap is
now
the 11th of september that year started
off as a beautiful day but when i
arrived on the east side of manhattan on
my way to work like many others i saw a
plane flying screamingly low
shortly after i reached my office the
first plane hit
on that day around 3 000 new yorkers
were killed
many of the bodies were never recovered
many of the scars will never heal
[Music]
one of the many businesses hit hard by
the tragedy was ohara's irish pub
one of the closest bars to the twin
towers
it's been here since 1983.
co-owner mike started working here not
long after it opened when o'hara's was a
popular happy hour destination for local
office workers including many that
worked in the world trade center
there were about six of us in here when
the first tower collapsed in an instant
this place was covered in dust and
debris
it was like a snowstorm at night it was
pitch black
and what was it like in the days that
followed
it was pretty miserable you were
devastated that your
business was
pretty much gone and then
it was tough finding out constantly that
guys you knew were killed
on top of the emotional and human toll
the physical damage was immense
o'hares is here
one block south from the world trade
center
after the attacks buildings all over
this area were either destroyed
or severely damaged
this area housed 30 percent of lower
manhattan's office space
a hundred thousand workers were
temporarily displaced
the city was given 20 billion dollars of
federal funding to rebuild lower
manhattan
and two months after the attacks a new
city administration
headed by mayor michael bloomberg was
elected into office
new yorkers have always made the
sacrifices necessary to achieve a better
tomorrow and there will be a better
tomorrow
dan doctoroff was deputy mayor for
economic development
we have to take this opportunity and
turn it into something
that we otherwise wouldn't be able to do
the team didn't want to just rebuild the
16-acre plot of land that had been
destroyed but redeveloped the whole city
it marked the start of a new era of huge
municipal
ambition i've come to meet dan at the
jewel in the crown of new york's
redevelopment program
hudson yards
what we found was new yorkers wanted to
make the city greater than ever they
wanted to rebuild
and it was that attitude that when mike
bloomberg and i and others came into
city hall i think we drove to try and
transform new york
built on the west side of manhattan on
top of the storage yard for long island
railroad trains
hudson yards is a 28-acre mixed-use
development of shops homes and
businesses
so this right here yeah is the
headquarters warner media now
uh kkr wells fargo in new york and as
you go further down there's a
headquarters for blackrock and facebook
and the next building
and then pfizer in the building after
that and there have been literally i
think maybe 70 or 80 buildings built in
this area over the last 15 years this
right here is building i'm particularly
proud of the shed the times of london
called it the coolest building in the
world and it's almost like a transformer
so what was here before what we're
seeing it was an empty open rail yard
yeah
transforming a derelict no man's land
into a glossy new neighborhood wasn't
cheap hudson yards cost 25 billion
dollars
to fund it dan and his team had to get
creative
we
got money to rebuild lower manhattan but
nothing for the rest of the city and the
city was facing a massive budget crisis
i mean huge and so we created the
largest tax equipment financing district
ever in the united states
basically going to bondholders and say
trust us if you build it they will come
and they did and you can see the results
there's been a massive amount of
buildings built which will generate the
city an enormous profit into the future
but as the most expensive private
property development in american history
critics have accused hudson yards of
catering to a global elite rather than
the local community
what do you think you got wrong you know
i think that the biggest thing was the
city became less affordable more people
came to this city than we accommodated
in terms of housing production that's
still the biggest problem new york has
today
from 2010 to 2019
for every five new jobs created in new
york only one new unit of housing was
built
prices skyrocketed
you'd need to be a millionaire to buy a
one bed apartment in hudson yards today
yet close to one in five people in the
city live in poverty
this inequality was laid bare during the
pandemic
poor communities suffered much higher
covet 19 deaths than their wealthier
neighbors
and so we need a new model of inclusive
growth
that actually responds to the inequities
that we've certainly knew were here
before covid
but are
even that much more evident but
stimulating growth is more of a
challenge today than it was after 9 11.
in the past year the city has received
14 billion dollars from the federal
government which is less than what it
received after the terror attacks
yet more than double the amount of jobs
have been lost
over by ground zero businesses like
o'hara's have been hit hard
so what's it been like over the past
year or so since the pandemic for you
guys
yeah this one was a little tough it
wasn't just our little
area that was destroyed the whole world
that was down
what about government support during the
pandemic do you think there's been
enough do you wish the government had
done something else i'm sorry what what
about government support i'm sorry
uh government support truthfully
really haven't had anything out of that
at the start of the pandemic the federal
government launched a 944 billion dollar
fund for small businesses
the paycheck protection program
but initially
only 12 of eligible businesses in new
york city actually received it
many more have since but those who got
the loan didn't always see the benefits
you got the pvp loan to pay your
employees
but nobody was open
so
it just kept
people off of unemployment which they
would have been getting with the extra
bonus the same money anyway so it didn't
help anybody in that respect then
they came out with the big restaurant
relief fund
you know most people
didn't get anything
since the start of the pandemic more
than 3 000 small businesses in new york
city have been forced to close their
doors for good
[Music]
one area that has been especially hard
hit is chinatown
a neighborhood in lower manhattan where
nearly a quarter of residents live below
the poverty line
it's an area that is often overlooked in
times of crisis
after 9 11 roadblocks and subway
closures made it impossible to access
chinatown
for weeks 75 of the workforce was out of
a job but at the time loans were only
given to those closer to ground zero and
many here waited months before receiving
aid
[Music]
stop
helping the rich you know with the money
going to the buildings and the
businesses and all and stop robbing us
the poor
during the pandemic the city did not
learn from these post-9 11 failures
[Music]
parts of chinatown were again left out
of a loan program for small businesses
due to its shared zip code with more
affluent neighborhoods support didn't
come until july 2021 well over a year
into the pandemic
but there's another challenge facing
chinatown
since the pandemic began an age-old
problem has reared its ugly head
anti-asian hate crime
in 2019 there was one case
in the first half of this year there
have been 102.
wellington chen is the head of the
chinatown partnership a non-profit that
supports businesses and the local
community and he's had first-hand
experience of this rise in anti-asian
racism
just a couple months ago straight down
the block at the end of this block a
chinese young man was working home and i
see this stranger way in the back come
running up to him and he plunged an
8-inch butcher knife straight into his
back
today wellington is going shop to shop
handing out whistles to asian americans
so they can alert others if they are
attacked
good nice
we consulted a crisis management expert
and they said to us every time after
crisis they need to find who's the devil
and they need to find a scapegoat to
blame and unfortunately this time is us
with the asian faces
after 9 11 it was muslim americans who
suffered
across america recorded anti-muslim hate
crimes increased from 28 in 2000 to 481
the year of the twin towers attacks
they started talking about terrorism and
so on they started looking at me as if i
was the one that did it
back then the nypd launched mass
surveillance programs targeting muslims
often without proof of wrongdoing
a practice that has since been widely
condemned
this time however the nypd has created a
task force dedicated to stopping
anti-aging hate crimes
but many in the local community still
feel unsafe
it's causing a vicious cycle because the
more anxiety you create the less chance
of people wanting to come out and it
costs the business additional hardship
so we now have a second virus that we
have no vaccine for
[Music]
to help communities survive tough times
it's clear affordable housing support
for small business and effective
policing are all essential but that
takes money
and it's here that the city faces
another challenge
the outpouring of community after 9 11
kept people in new york
but this time many of the city's
wealthiest residents have left
by february 2021 a year after the
pandemic started almost half the
residents in new york's business hubs
had moved away
just a five percent loss of new yorkers
making six figures would result in an
annual loss of 933 million dollars in
tax revenue
roughly the amount allocated for the
city's health department
new york has some huge challenges ahead
and while some post-9 11 redevelopment
was a success
the city needs to learn lessons from
what its leaders got wrong
in november 2021 new yorkers go to the
polls to elect their next mayor
the likely winner will be the democratic
candidate eric adams
an ex-cop he has vowed to reform the
police department and help fight crimes
against the asian community
i'm not new to this fight
i'm not new to standing up on behalf of
people
it doesn't matter of the ethnicity this
is still our city
he wants to expand local tax credits for
low-income families
invest in underperforming schools and
improve public housing
and he has a pandemic aid relief plan
that aims to cut the red tape stopping
people getting money today
but funding is going to remain a
challenge
mayor adams assuming he gets elected is
going to have to be really creative and
coming up with resources to make the
kinds of investments that give people
um confidence in the future of the city
what lessons did you learn from 911 that
you think would apply to the to to mayor
adams first year in office leadership
really matters having a vision that
inspires people
really matters bringing people back to
this city
matters
new york always comes back it's just a
question of how long it takes
[Music]
thanks for watching
to read the economist coverage of the
20th anniversary of the september 11th
attacks click the link and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]
you